it's no secret there's lots of money to
be made owning a sports team media deals
and fan enthusiasm soaring it's been
really hard not to make money now with
more cash than ever vying for a place in
pro sports and a reckoning around
equality and opportunity underway the
biggest payday may be on the women's
side of the game alex morgan
i look at the women's sports market
similar to venture there's a lot more
upside
how'd that go in female athletes and
fans have been trailblazing this change
for generations historically and more
recently it's been a painful process as
women fight institutions and systems
seemingly designed to diminish and even
at times abuse them
it's not just a basic issue of right and
wrong but also a question about power
and money
and the conversation around how to
invest in women's sports and who is
writing the checks has taken on a
different urgency and dimension perhaps
leading to a new and very lucrative era
of opportunity
imagine if you had a chance to go back
in time and buy the boston celtics in
1957. if you make the investment now
given how low franchise prices are i
would expect in 20 25 years your
investment's gonna be worth you know
many many times what you just paid for
so we're here in los angeles on a
freeway naturally
this is one of the great sports towns
some of the most notable franchises
across all sports you think about the
lakers you think about the dodgers
everyone seems though to be talking
about the newest team on the scene and
that's angel city the women's soccer
team is coming to los angeles all thanks
to natalie portman angel city fc is the
product of actress and activist natalie
portman and kara nortman a partner at an
early stage investment firm they made
headlines last year when they announced
plans to bring a national women's soccer
league team to la
their star-studded list of investors
includes jennifer garner jessica
chastain america ferreira uzo aduba and
eva longoria
the leading founding investor is alexis
ohanian he's the co-founder of reddit
and of course the husband to serena
williams their toddler daughter alexis
olympia ohanian is also an investor
they brought in a third co-founder to
run the team a veteran of building
businesses her name is julie irman and
right now she's still building out their
office space
so this is a real startup i mean
we're still waiting for fiverr hi
good to see you yeah this is the future
home of angel city
so we've got two big conference rooms
here
and then we'll call this the bullpen for
lack of a better term right now i have
to start using more soccer references
than other sports um what's really neat
with this blank wall is we'll have a
projector so we can project games on on
the wall but we're also going to have
pull downs so we'll have a pull down
green screen pull down white screen and
a pull down step and repeat so that we
can do content shoots here merch shoots
here we have player signings we can just
create the atmosphere here ehrman's a
native angelino who came up through
media and technology and has a knack for
getting into businesses at points of
inflection i was an entrepreneur in
college my stepfather was an
entrepreneur
he taught us two things growing up the
first was
work for yourself
and be in control of your own destiny
and if you can't work for yourself be on
the revenue side of the business
while valuations have continued to rise
in a lot of sports this is a tough
business in in many ways and it's an
especially tough business when it comes
to
professional women's sports sure this is
not for the faint of heart in many ways
over 90 of all sports teams globally
don't make money right and so we looked
at all this information and said we're
female founders that's different we're
going to raise money like it's a startup
which is different we're going to drive
to profitability because if we can show
we can make money being different in
those other ways that's going to be
pretty
significant
julie ehrman sent me a linkedin message
and was just like hey i hear you're the
woman to talk to in sponsorship and i'd
love to talk to you about an idea this
is jess smith she's the head of revenue
for angel city and her idea was to blend
angel city's goal of profit with social
impact i put together a business
proposal for her and said hey this is
how i think you should go to market and
it was really that if you're going to
walk in a room and tell people that
you're standing for change how do you
hold yourself accountable and also the
partner accountable and really the way
to do that is through dollars when we
started talking to brands we also
launched the angel city sponsorship
model where we give 10 of our
sponsorship dollars back into the
community through our social
impact platform so when angel city sells
their front of kit sponsorship to
doordash 10 of that sale goes to
combating food insecurity in los angeles
this purpose-driven advertising has
helped to attract the likes of birdies
heineken tecate and gatorade
we said from the beginning we wanted to
build an organization where mission and
capital could go exist so what does that
mean it means that we want to set higher
expectations what does that mean right
it means that we lead with passion and
purpose to drive to profitability and
that is the key sentence that we make
decisions based on every single day
recently though angel city's impact in
the world of sports would take on an
added importance
the national women's soccer league faces
a reckoning over charges that it ignored
abuse of its players former nwsl players
have accused former coach paul riley of
sexual coercion a stark reminder of just
how backwards and broken parts of the
system are came in late september when
the athletic published an investigation
detailing allegations of sexual
misconduct including harassment and
coerced sex it also detailed how earlier
accusations weren't fully investigated
or disciplined by the league
our institution failed us
the system right it's the people in
power not just the coach but the
leadership team
paul riley couldn't be reached for
comment and has denied the allegations
the league suspended play for the
weekend after the athletic report
published and forced the resignation of
the commissioner lisa baird
she said in a statement that she takes
full responsibility for her role in the
allegations and is sorry for the pain
many are feeling social media was filled
with indignation and anger including
from megan rupino who tweeted quote burn
it all down let all their heads roll
i hope we're in a real moment of of
reckoning where we can turn this into
real change and hopefully save the
league because as it stands right now
that's not really the league any of us
want to be a part of
angel city may be part of that change
sinead fairley whose allegations of
long-term abuse were detailed in the
athletic cited angel city as part of her
inspiration to go public
i
i think i started reading the article at
5 15 in the morning pacific time
and i don't think i've ever done this
but i i was in and out of tears all day
this is angela huckles a two-time gold
medalist for u.s soccer and founding
investor for angel city this is
something that affects all of us
it doesn't just affect the soccer
community this is something that we are
struggling with in our society and the
world
and this is something that we need to
get right the u.s soccer federation
which governs the nwsl retained former
deputy attorney general sally yates to
lead an investigation into the league as
it hopes to rebuild its trust with
players
for me and i think our organization
and the work that we're continuing to do
on the daily it's to make sure that we
are moving forward in providing
a better environment and a place that is
stronger than it's ever been before to
make sure that these women can play be
celebrated and feel safe
and and that's not
an unacceptable thing to ask for
[Music]
the harsh reality for the nwsl is not
only does it need to regain the support
and trust of its players but it will
also need time to develop its fan and
sponsor base
and if it's looking for a role model
look no further than the wnba grinder
finds terrazzi
it's gone she got it the goat delivers
again
[Applause]
at 25 years old the league is one of the
oldest most well-known and most
successful women sports leagues in the
world
and its stars are getting more attention
than ever whether it's from activism
efforts around the league are more blue
chip advertisers featuring them in
commercials i sold a car to sue bird
11 all-star appearances can you imagine
i mean i'm working on it but if you
measure the wnba against the nba it's
still a massive gap
attendance for the nba averages more
than 17 000 a game while the wnba
averages between six and seven thousand
and estimates of the combined revenue
for the nba it's about 7.9 billion
dollars versus the wnba at 60 million i
think the big issue people have with
women's sports is that relative to men's
sports is a lot smaller this is david
berry he's a professor who's written
extensively about the economics of
sports especially women's sports and he
argues that the biggest factor between
men and women's leagues is time
wnba is smaller because it's only 25
years old and if you look at the nba
when it was 25 years old it looks a lot
like the wnba today the nba back in the
late 1960s
was getting about six seven thousand
fans a game nobody really paid much
attention to the league and in 25 30
years wnba is going to look a lot like
the nba
as david explains this decades-long
growth has been true in almost all pro
sports
it usually takes generations to develop
emotional attachment to teams
take the pittsburgh steelers who were
purchased by art rooney in 1933
for a whopping 53 000 in today's dollars
art rooney is investing in a sports
league where 85 to 90 percent of the
previous franchises completely went out
of business but he does it anyways he
loves football so he puts his money into
this thing for 40 years rooney kept
putting money into a steelers franchise
that won nothing they went to one
playoff game in 40 years and in that
playoff game they scored no points he
never saw a playoff point for 40 years
and he kept putting money into it
eventually
a fan base develops people become
emotionally attached to it and the
steelers that are inherited by his
grandson are worth a billion dollars
and nearly two decades later art rooney
the second franchise is worth 3.4
billion
ownership is an area angel city thinks
it can improve on instead of having its
future rest on the shoulders of one
owner it instead has a diversified
ownership across a large group including
an all-star list of former players we're
putting
seats except this time we're owners it
started in an email really julie foughty
mia ham sent to the rest of some of the
players about this opportunity to invest
in angel city and bringing women's
professional soccer to los angeles
i think it was probably the quickest
response that i've seen from about you
know
10 10 women and that ownership group
would only grow
we have over 60 owners they're all
incredible they all bring something
different to the platform i was telling
someone the other day that i literally
don't think there is an owner that
hasn't done something for angel city the
story i've told in some rooms about that
is being in a
sponsorship pitch talking to a beer
brand and a gentleman's in the room and
he says hey i'm from the lifestyle side
of the brand and candidly i don't follow
sports but i have to tell you i know
everything about angel city because i
follow sophia bush and what's really
incredible about our ownership group
when you think about the power of angel
city is that each one of them has their
own audience and each one of them are
sharing things about us and aligning
with us on things that they're
passionate about and the expectation
when they invested in angel city was
you have to care about the purpose and
you have to be
available to help us you know grow the
business and have a positive impact on
our community and everybody signed up
for that but beyond passion for owners
for more money to continue to flow into
women's sports it's going to need more
evidence that it can be successful and
for investors that means data
[Music]
everyone's heard of the moneyball effect
you know we're increasingly using data
to help our players get the most out of
their careers out of their performance
and on the business side of sports um
unfortunately there's been a lot of
just hey that's how we've always done
business angela ruggiero has played more
games in a usa hockey jersey than any
man or woman winning gold silver and
bronze medals after her career on the
eyes she got an mba at harvard and set
up sports innovation lab it's a
boston-based company that uses data
science to help teens and leagues
understand their fans and figure out how
to better engage them and to be clear to
help them find new ways to make revenue
off them we watch sports differently i
watch sports differently
half the time i have my my second screen
on my hand i'm flipping through scores
checking out highlights got my red zone
maybe i'm on twitch over here we're
doing things very differently we're all
shifting in how we consume
contribute to sports create content
interact with athletes model shifting
overnight
in the early days of the sports industry
you had a very localized fan so
ticket sales were really the biggest
proponent of of revenue then as you
start to move into the 1940s and 50s you
have the advent of broadcast media that
allows for fans to start following more
than just their their local team and
that also starts to translate into them
becoming more consumers of sports so
they start
buying you start seeing merchandising
and sponsorship opportunities start to
to really take off
and now what we've really moved into in
this digital age with the advent of the
internet of smartphones of social media
we're moving into what we call the age
of the fluid fan and they believe that
just as the advent of television helped
fuel new areas of revenue in the age of
the global fan
new technology and social platforms will
do the same in the age of the fluid fan
we see an evolving
media landscape where all fans
want more than just the game
now they want more online they want to
understand the athletes they want that
netflix docu series
but fans of women's sports per the fan
project data
suggests that
they want it more
in a report published earlier this year
sil outlines how fans of women's sports
are ahead of the curve when it comes to
how technology is changing fandom you
can't be a lazy women sports fan you
can't just turn on the game you can't
just find your content wherever you want
you've we've almost
forced the hand of this market to be
digitally savvy we forced the hand of
this market
to behave in ways maybe they were
uncomfortable but they got over that
hurdle and they were the first to do it
what that gives us is this incredible
group of what we call early adopters and
this has been used in other industries
before sometimes they're called hyper
users when i was at spotify we called
them trend setters but essentially what
you need to understand about early
adopters is that typically they will
only represent one to ten percent of a
given fan base they can represent as
much as 50 to 80 of the revenue
potential that you can drive and while
there's potentially a lot of money to be
made in understanding the behavior of
women's sports fans the report also made
clear there's a big opportunity in
women's sports themselves
in our analysis we looked at a number of
sources that predicted the global sports
business market would be around 800
billion by 2030. we believe
if we invest in women's sports now the
opportunity for women's sports could be
a third of that 800 billion dollar
market in its report sil proposes what
it calls a community-based monetization
model it outlines how women's sports can
capitalize on the shifting fan behavior
by producing more story-driven content
distributing it on new emerging
platforms and measuring quality of
engagement over quantity
you have to approach this market with a
focus on it's a different fan don't just
take the same model do it differently
build out your revenue in new ways and
that actually is going to unlock in our
opinion
not just a better roi better return
but also it's where the puck is headed
if i can use a hockey analogy you've
actually created a market of your future
consumer that's your current fan of
women's sports they're already there
angel city won't play any games here at
bank of california stadium until the
spring of 2022
and while they have good financial
backing and have made early sponsorship
deals they're still going to need to
attract fans
and the best path to that is through
their players
we think fandom has really changed and
it's changed mostly because of social
media where i'm a fan of the player
first their team second and then the
league third and so when you think about
the asset that is most valuable to you
being your 22 24 person roster the way
that i can create a connection with that
player that can then translate to the
club and then
allow us the ability to monetize is to
tell the story of who that player is
good morning angel city fans i am so
excited to be coming home hope to see
you soon
and for angel city they needed a star
and it's hard to find a better option
than la's own kristin press
there it is
the moment they've been waiting for a
native of southern california she's
angel city's first and currently only
player on the roster
and before angel city plays any games on
the pitch they'll rely on press to help
build awareness
that's especially important for a new
team in a nine-year-old circuit that's
the third try at a us pro women's soccer
league
i may not know there's an nwsl i may not
know there's a national women's soccer
league but i know there's an alex morgan
i know megan repino i know kristin press
and when i start to follow them then i
find out oh wait they play for
the orlando pride or they are soon to
play for angel city angel city will need
a roster full of name recognition like
press to drive interest to their team
that has been the theory on the nwsl
from its inception to connect the
popularity and historic success of the
u.s women's national team to a more
traditional league
but at a time when player trust in that
league is being challenged angel city is
attempting to help provide support for
all women soccer players both future and
past
they've been producing a profile series
around young talent in the la area and
recently announced a plan to create a
player's fund so that retiring
professional players can receive money
for education in their post-career life
there is a huge gap right now
from the time that you retire to the
time that you are entering into your
next career path so that's one of the
things and ways that we like to
think about player care
is looking at that player holistically
and it's not just about the time that
they're playing in the league but it's
you know what are they doing afterwards
and how can we help to foster and
connect
um that community as well
it's an acknowledgment that while the
early returns look good for angel city
this is a long-term investment in the
sport and that they're committed not
only to fielding a successful team but
building a successful sports ecosystem
one that goes beyond their team or even
the current
league our aspiration is to be a global
brand
and it's been our aspiration from day
one and the reason is because if you're
a global brand you could have the most
impact
full stop it's a platform that stands
for quality and impact and if we can you
know develop a relationship with our
community that goes way beyond wins and
losses we have the ability to impact
their lives
the future of the nwsl may remain in
question for some time
but it's clear from the outpouring of
support from fans that they intend to
support the players wherever they
ultimately play
and it's never been more clear that who
funds and ultimately who profits from
women's sports have the opportunity to
make big changes in not just sports but
society
yes women's sports is the right thing to
do yes we should be investing in
women we should be creating role models
for all of society yes check check check
but there's more than that women's
sports is actually a big business it's
unlocking revenue it's unlocking
potential understanding of where fandom
in general is going but you have an
opportunity to get in now with women's
sports and from an investment
perspective it's one of the biggest
differences between men's and women's
sports
for the most popular sports in the world
to buy into a team in the men's space is
maybe one of the hardest deals to close
but for those same sports the women's
game is open for business
[Music]
you